so wartete was ist denn wenn man in die
andere richtung springen theoretisch da
hoch quasi du musst auch in diese gruppe
sondern das gelände ist nicht runter das
skelett schießt mich runter aber der
liebe gott sohn zu der weiteren folge
der aus dem job mit meniar media web mit
aus und jermaine nicht einfach ja genau
du bist ja auf dem komplett neuen stand
sage ich mal du hast dich ja eben
geradezu mit ihm und ich sag immer
ebenso dass die lang denn das ist sie
ein abteil da wurde mir von der karte
gesagt das hier ist ein
das team ist aus dem chaos herausfinden
und da weiß ich genau den weg und zwar
du musst hier entlang
auf diese steinplatten das wort chaos
hier
weil das aber nicht weit gekommen oder
von hier runter und dann hier weiter
wenn auch alles richtig so ja es ist
verdammt
und da muss einfach da dem weg folgen
ihr habt ein falsches texture pack
tränen warte mal was ist los mit mir
wenn ich sinnlos mit diagramme während
ihr heute mit mir bei dies sinnlos mit
komme weil ich muss wieder sehen ich bin
ich habe vertrag wieder runter zu
springen wo muss ich jetzt ist ist das
wirklich sicher dass man darunter muss
ja 100 nutzern sich das kann du klingst
übrigens relativ krank ja ich bin ja
leider auch ein wenig erkältet
also passt auf der plan ist so
normalerweise müsste man knapp 1000
sprünge so gefühlte tausend sprüngen bis
dorthin noch mal springende aber ich
habe von dir dass abgeschaut mit den
ganzen abkürzen aber da sind auch die
springen springen wir einmal machen habe
ich das mal sehe also ich glaube jetzt
einfach mal den weg hier landen weil der
nähe der der weg ist falsch ich wenn ich
gleich sterbe okay ich bin tot jetzt
tätig einfach mal weg ist falsch rwe was
ist also der richtige weg der g2 warten
wir müssen auch darauf stehen kommen
einfach aber wir sind nicht so nicht so
grenzen eingebaut bei der epic jump
etwas immer so dass du nie irgendwann
den wänden hoch kraxeln konstruiert ist
überall so wir wollten hat vor der
partie gesagt alter jungs hier ist chaos
so hier musste lang und es hat man
runter springen muss doch doch wie geht
es weiter so und nicht runterfallen
kollege ich bin sicherer als du ja
roddick bot dann gucken wir als erste
herunterfällt
okay ich bin montag nicht naja jetzt von
dieser andere plattformen darunter das
kamen
ich habe gerade den bogen raus gezückt
ohne spaß wollte sich abknallen dann
nimmst du den bogen einfach war ich
traurig kollege was ist denn da los wenn
die wir dann ich dazu wollte er den weg
anschauen so beim gc entlang hier runter
und dann sind dann ist auch schon mal
diesen stein sprüngen auf und eben
gerade ja gut und wenn man jetzt habe
ich dir einmal also mehr oder weniger
durchgemacht kommt würde mich jetzt
zeige ich dass man hier ja so andere
seite
aber ich wollte immer ganz kurz das
jetzt hier meine folge ist auf einem
kanal kommt die frage beantworten warum
denn keine videos kamen
das liegt nicht daran sonst keine u das
liegt nicht daran dass ich irgendwie
gesagt habe okay ich sie zu hause vorm
pc aber nein gerade voll kein bockhorn
ii
ich bin einfach über gerade voll keinen
bock auf aufnehmen sondern dass sie ganz
einfach daran dass ich vor abitur
geschrieben habe das heißt drei
klausuren da man drei fächer
schriftlichen abitur hat die schreibt
man dann halt vorm abitur und das ist
auf jeden fall krass und da musste ich
auch eine menge lernen
und da war es halt nicht einfach so dass
ich dann schule bis 5 uhr hatte und dann
kann man nach hause dann hat man halt
einfach weiter gelernt und dann noch
irgendwie sport und sowas alle sondern
blieb youtube hat so ein bisschen auf
der strecke wenn man sich dann der
andere prioritäten setzt dafür möchte
ich mich entschuldigen ich habe das bei
twitter und facebook twitter weiß gar
nicht aber bei facebook habe ich auf
jeden fall gepostet
da folgt ein aber auch nicht jeder
deswegen muss man das hier noch mal auf
youtube werken also deswegen ein großes
entschuldigung an euch ich hoffe ihr
habt jetzt alle akzeptiert ich bin
übrigens durch aber jetzt kann wieder
regelmäßig videos ab heute computer
sorgt 9
ok jetzt hast du wieder was sagen glaubt
irgendwie nicht das geländer zum vierten
merken kannst glaube ich einfach nicht
bestimmen
ich glaube davon noch nicht wisst ihr
was eine frage wege wir können twitter
fragen waren und hier kommt eine frage
rein an den anderen komme was ist denn
los mit ihr wollt ihr gefragt war
diensten wenn dies denn weil ich es dann
los mit mir ich weiß nicht wen ich
erkältet bin ich ich hab aber hier
gerade bock auf die jump web und
ausgeschlafen einigermaßen ja und ja da
keine zeugen wir waren alle termine ab
gemacht hier 18 uhr bei rezept und war
hier 18 uhr war der gruppe 18 uhr 53
tore mit der aussage ich habe gerade
schlafen gelegt aber wegen einer
erkältung zu dies das erweitert mit der
kälte kaum schlafen gelegt wollte 15
minuten waren dann zwei stunden
minute da denkt sich ich mache ein zwei
stunden jetzt übertreibt will hier
können auch zwei stunden seien deswegen
sagt ich zwei stunden damit sich nach
mehr an hört eine historische frage ich
mich immer klassische bärbel wie man sie
auch im deutsch lk nehmen was ich auch
freunde jetzt komplett predigt mal ganz
ehrlich und du schaffst das
ich möchte das machen ich möchte ein
bisschen springen meister du kannst dich
töten und dann noch mal mit mir springen
da oben kommt da auch welche treffe ich
ihn treffe der jetzt kommt nein du musst
du den pfeilen von mir aus walter junger
ich habe ein herz junger lover hallo wo
junge dass das doch jetzt komme ich lass
das
was ist los mit dir mal in meinen magen
und gab bekannt dass hat man voll gehört
[ __ ] warum denn nicht kann
ich würde sterben
hallo ich kann es ja nicht mal schaffen
das ist das ist und machbar da drüben
was ist los mit den sprüngen hat mich
aufgehalten
ich hab ich mich gefragt was ist los mit
dem baum
sie kommen schon gastrolle als ob das
komplett geschafft hast ja habe ich kann
mich ab ich kann das ganze partie wie du
komm vorbei ich warte auf dich hört auf
mich jetzt abzuschießen älter packe ich
kann es ja gar nicht offen sondern bis
ins final angeschossen
weil ich da oben treffens war so
traumhaft jetzt aber kann mich noch
genau ein gelaufen auch wenn ich den
korridoren jetzt treffen da freue mich
aber da hast du schon werde vorzustellen
er war scheiße natürlich auch als front
row packe mit drehungen mache ich das
sehr
da kommt schon die auch du bewegst dich
aber immer und ich nicht oh ja kollege
dürfte warum hier möchte ich dennoch
hier ja okay ich bin auf dem weg jetzt
scheiße weil ich sinnlos mit dir
runtergefallen alter ich bin jetzt
erwartet die plattformen gesprungen und
einfach tot
um also weil du mich vielleicht für den
fall getroffen dass da netz fliegen
können wenn ich den treffen welche die
treffe donnerstag cool wenn ich so im
sprung gab es geht mir noch drei
versuche wenn ich danach nicht schaffe
dann häufig erst mal aber ich glaube wir
müssen auch gar nicht lange so lang wie
wir das wohl weil ich war ja da eben
durch schnell da drüben bei dem berg bin
ich raus gekommen und auf jeden fall bin
ich dann direkt gestorben weil ich da
raus katapultiert wurde und durch den
fall stand dann der karte ich bin ich
weiß nicht ob das gewollt ist sogar wo
bist du wenn es mal einen anderen weg
lang gelaufen
ja ich solle den weg hier raus finden
aus dem chaos und a ha okay hier ist
falsch ist falsch war ich schon mal da
ist das allerdings
aber hier war ich ja schon mal rein soll
ich bin jetzt gerade hinter dir auch da
hüpfe ich über die plattform aber hier
war ich 100 nicht schon mal aber keine
ahnung ob das richtig ist nie es ist
nicht richtig wir müssen wirklich da
drüben wo wir eben gerade auch schon
waren oder von dort in dem endlich
richtig ist seht ihr wenn das licht
eines ich bin jetzt hier in den berg
drinnen bei diesem lila pinken tunnel ja
nicht weil ich ja gar nicht ich meine da
unten den berg hinein
das heißt sollte sicher falsch da wo wir
halten am anfang auch schon mal
gesprungen sind da wollen müssen wir
wählen
da müssen wir hin und dann irgendwie von
da aus in den berg unten rein und da
sind halt wir sprung platt mit
sprungkraft da müssen wir auf da war ich
ja eben auch schon drauf hab ich so hoch
katapultiert der erstochenen hier lang
springt dann ist mal wieder jedoch nicht
erwartet ich bin mal kurz gelang diesen
anwalt wohl zu sorgen
hüttenberg ohne spaß war schon da habe
ich doch das habe ich gerade eben
gemacht alter und tötest du mich denn
wiederwahl zu schaffen dass keiner die
weltlichen liedern einkommen tötet mich
in ordnung ist in ordnung
doch ich hoffe auch nichts dagegen ja
contipark wollten endlich mal den will
ich habe extreme komme ich habe einiges
gegen de poopst ja nichts gegen dich
einfach so du liegst du bist einfach
kacke
aber ja er will einfach erst mal war es
endlich los mit dir
da ist so eine frage die kann sich beim
baurecht immer stellen ja ich sag dir
wusste entgegne kollege herkommt als wo
es langgeht wird nicht so ein absturz
kandidat wie du jetzt mach ruft erwartet
und das also wie gesagt der weg den wir
eben auch schon gemacht haben die ganze
zeit wo du immer abgestürzt ist den
müssen wir schaffen genau den hier nach
dem 1
denn ich war richtig ach ja ach ja und
kosten
das ist aber die beste abkürzung
schlechthin
savas ob du dir auch findest ja mache
ich
nein nicht nur dem baum
ich habe viel bessere abkürzung jahr
guck mir zu siehst du mich ich bin halt
eine höhle wo ich wohne freund wurde
versucht das mich zu treffen
lange hatte ich glaube ich von einer
anderen stelle aussehen oh mann alter
auch alter nicht von hier
da weist jetzt habe ich meistercup
kürzungen ab boden herum denn darunter
was abkürzung finden
ich habe jedoch geboten com mit ok damit
also also als wir springen hier entlang
dann hier auf hierunter o mein gott im
sprung im sprung komme im sprung ist
sagte korte
das war richtig cool egal was du bist
auch du bist eine abkürzung vorbei hier
ist doch ein baum
hier kannst du doch lang springt warum
meinst du ja dann hier über kreta ok
genauso wieder läuft das dann
ich bin vorne ich bin da in der höhle
ist auf jeden fall richtig gut einfach
tot okay ich habe da von hinten zu geben
aber da oben auf dem berg stehen
ich habe extra zum rennen kommen aber
sonst auch schon in dieser folge jetzt
beenden erwartet worden war der ein mal
noch gucken ja cool ich habe daraus
geschlossen hey ich hab das ende von der
karte war aber ich glaube dass es eng
ist warte mal
damit kommt es schnell wir wollen doch
gucken doch in deiner vorher ob wir
schon beim ende sind okay tiere war
stark da war richtig stark
es war richtig stark noch mal 1000
so was ist denn wenn man in die andere
richtung springen theoretisch da hoch
quasi du musst einfach in diese kuppel
soll das iglu das gelände ist nicht
runter das skelett schießt mich runter
oh mein gott ich könnte heulen
ich hab's getötet ok alles als mich
nächster versuch so komme ja und
congratulations jakob lese torsten may
16 vor downloading im play-off wie
engine webkit mir heads-up als könig so
ist von dmc forum ev record review panel
11 uk trailer as well as the pips 11
youtube com / ausrufezeichen
wir haben es geschafft wir sind durch
conny für die allgemeine durch aber
jetzt kommt ja jetzt gerade überzeugen
hier mit dem geil texture pack sie das
auch immer richtig cool aus
bongo wo mein gott eigentlich wollen wir
noch haben wir ja schon termine
abgemacht zu machen wir sind wieder
aufnehmen und so auf einmal vorbei
so tragisch ich habe die sprünge trat
ist ja egal ich würde sagen wir machen
jetzt erstmal alles voll mit ihr und wir
finden dass man nicht auch nicht hier
kommen wir machen das gleich noch einen
neuen abschluss worten mach halt überall
an den wänden das ganze so verwirkliche
macht schön gefällt mir erzählt wir
wollte erstmals elf tote das ist die
neue energieformen in minecraft der
scheiß auf erneuerbare energien
das ist die zukunft fehlt die tnt paket
partei dies auf jeden fall
pro halle l pro contra alles aber
prozent ich finde ich auch gut ankomme
was willst du wieder zu den karten
bewerten
von celina wollten würde ich der karte 7
km lauf gesagt
also ich bin echt mal kritisch
thailänder still weil ich finde es mega
geil dass wenn die ressourcen beck haben
also eine sechser pack für die karte
jedoch finde ich einfach es fehlten hier
war die betten
die haben mir richtig starke fehlt die
sprünge waren immer schön gestalten da
gab es unterschiedliche sprünge
unterschiedliche ideen des wegen sieben
punkte sind ja auch nicht schlecht also
die karte bekommt von mir sieben punkte
die kräuter mir gefiel das sind alles
aspekte die ich auch nennen möchte und
vor allem dass man einfach so leicht
tricksen kann regt mich mega auf das man
einfach so abkürzung finden kann das war
bei der app die mir halt so sonst und
diese reihe gewöhnt sind
das war dann nicht so da kommt man echt
nie gegen die am rand hoch kraxeln mal
durch einen zufall oder so das war echt
die so daran immer zwei blöcke hoch und
hier konnte recht einfach nur alt werden
von unseren paar springen landschaft
geworfen um die landschaft wird
sicherlich gar keine gedanken gemacht es
wird jetzt auch keine großen sachen hier
irgendwie gebaut oder sowieso ein super
mario der epic knapp oder so oder so ein
gutes ambiente über so ziemlich
vielleicht sogar sechs punkte geben auch
respekt waldgarten die map an sich hat
spaß gemacht aber nicht sogar wieder
gibt muss man sagen da leistet der bund
40 viel viel bessere arbeit muss man auf
jeden fall
auf jeden fall hin völlig recht okay gut
ich habe jetzt das ganze tier hier die
folge soll auch heute noch online kommen
am wochenende auch ein bisschen frech
auf wie pilz gebaut auf dem berg wo wir
vor unserem bett hatten
kannst du gekommen bist dass du nicht in
dem das tnt stellt mit ihrem tolles
abschlussbild habe hier kommen wir jetzt
so ein penis achter macht times hat nur
ja gut okay okay will den schalter
kommen wir machen sie drücken machen
dass wir im schalter hier schönes bild
die mit einem schalter des golden mein
gott die ganze karte explodiert meine
freunde
alter gaul nochmals reagieren viele
wrestler mit seiner bürger buller kirche
an silvester feedback bekomme auch mal
das ganze außenluft und alles leider
fehlt was ist denn los mit euch hier ja
werten dir die ganze sprengungen
durchgeführt und ist los mit ihm
ja richtig gehört bei mir liegt sehr
schön um geht auch alles weiter das sind
sogar als sohn lernt funktioniert ja
celik wir können glaubst du noch ein
bisschen spring naja können wir wirklich
alles kaputt gemacht natürlich extra
damit wir noch springen können bisschen
etwas ganz anderem dass ihr noch
heftiger aussieht
ja da bin ich wenn ich's nicht wach und
den block
sie schmecken lassen lasst das hey hey
nein du sollst dich hinterher na ja gut
egal leute wenn es euch gefallen hat
lasst eine bewertung der schaut doch mal
vorbei wenn die anderen immer noch nicht
gesehen haben sollten sonst sonst wäre
die welt untergehen